now just a day after learning Biden's
student loan forgiveness plan would cost
400 billion dollars we're finally seeing
a major legal challenge to it here with
all the details is Trace Gallagher Fox's
Chief Breaking News correspondent and
brand new anchor of Fox News at night so
excited about that Trace congrats again
on the new gig
what can you tell us so for now about
this lawsuit uh Laura thank you first of
all the lawsuit itself is pretty cut and
dried the Pacific Legal Foundation a
Libertarian Law Firm says President
Biden's plan to forgive a half trillion
dollars in student loan debt is
flagrantly illegal because quoting here
only Congress has the power to pass laws
and spend money under the Constitution
but it's interesting because the
plaintiff in the lawsuit is a man named
Frank Garrison he's a lawyer for Pacific
Legal Foundation or plf and it turns out
Mr Garrison took out federal student
loans to pay for law school and after
paying down those loans for 10 years he
is now getting debt relief under Public
service loan forgiveness now that's a
program for borrowers who work in public
service for non-profits but in three
States including Indiana where Frank
Garrison lives the Biden debt relief
plan would subject him to state taxes
which would make him worse off than
simply repaying his Federal Loan and
because of those damages plf argues that
Garrison has legal standing to soothe
the Department of Education you see the
map there by the way we should note four
other states are considering also
imposing state taxes on those who get
Biden's debt relief today the White
House was asked about the lawsuit watch
Biden Harris Administration student loan
plan are trying to stop it because they
know it will provide much needed again
relief for Working Families anyone who
does not want to to give that debt
relief and can choose to opt out
Garrison and plf say there is no way for
him to opt out of the tax we should note
the Congressional budget office you
referred to this estimates the relief
plan will cost 430 billion dollars other
studies put the number a few hundred
billion dollars higher Laura
my goodness Trace thank you and we're
going to be tuning in I cannot wait on
October 3rd congrats again thank you
thank you very much all right joining me
now is the lead attorney on the case
Caleb kruckenberg of the Pacific Legal
Foundation Caleb we've been waiting for
a lawsuit like this now the response to
your critics saying that your suit has
no standing
because you're not an aggrieved party
what are the damages to you in the
Pacific Legal Foundation
well the question is not what's the
damages to me or the Pacific Legal
Foundation it's it's to the people that
are getting this student loan
cancellation
forced upon them and for my client Frank
Garrison who happens to be one of my
colleagues I mean the damages are pretty
clear he is going to be stuck with a tax
bill that he didn't ask for uh for this
cancellation that he doesn't want that's
going to put him in worse position than
if if nothing happened
um and to the extent that the White
House just said you know we heard the
clip they said well nobody's going to
get this if they don't want it that's
just not true the the Department of
Education is still on their website
today says that as many as 8 million
people in the U.S are going to get
automatic cancellation
um at least starting this week
potentially
now Caleb uh Larry tribe tweeted about
the lawsuit saying the big weakness of
it is the strength the statutory ground
at which Biden's plan stands both under
the heroes act and under the health and
Education Act
Caleb he went on to say that the lawsuit
was a stretch so again focusing on those
two acts the president is supposedly
finding the ability to appropriate
essentially hundreds of billions of
dollars
well I think just take a step back and
and think about how absurd that is that
it's even an argument that the president
can all by himself just appropriate 500
billion dollars or I mean we'll take the
conservative estimate 400 billion
dollars I mean that is a ridiculous
amount of money but if you look at the
heroes act and that's really the statute
that the Department of Education is
relying on the president is relying on
that was that was a bill that was passed
in 2003 in reaction to the Iraq War all
right we got to go but we got the point
you can't go back to Iraq and vets to
spend 400 billion dollars I think tribe
is wrong I think you're right we'll see
Caleb thanks hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else